We ended the last lecture.
Um,
or actually I ended my last lecture, not,
uh, the last lecture was, was was Matt.
Um,
I ended my last lecture on Paradise
regained with a brief consideration of the
riddle of the Sphinx.
And Satan was compared to the
Sphinx who had the sphinx,
who had thrown herself off the as meany
and steep when her riddle had been
discovered.
And,
and the son of God you'll remember was
implicitly compared to Oedipus, um,
who had figured out the riddle
of his own identity with,
by means of his exchange with this sphinx.
I think it can be sent to Samson agonists.
Ds is more explicitly concerned with
riddles and with riddling even then
paradise regained was one
of the key moments. Although
this isn't anything that,
that Milton does very much with one of
the key moments of the story of Samson
that we get from the
book of judges in the,
in the Bible involve Samson's posing
of this big riddle, the riddle of the,
of the, of the honey and
the lion. And it's Sampson,
at least in the judges in the
judge's version of the story,
who can be seen as assuming
the role of the Sphinx.
He poses the riddles and it's really
his duty throughout his life, uh,
to know when it is.
You should reveal the answer to the riddle
to the secret and Samsung agonists ds
as I think a profoundly
interested in this,
in this problem.
And it's continually asking the question,
how do you know when it's time?
How do you know when it's time to,
to reveal your secrets or to use the
language that Milton uses in the seventh
sonnet? Um, how soon? Half the time.
How do you know when it
is that you have ripened?
That's a riddle. That is the, it's the,
it's the job of Samson
in Samsung agonists,
gs to figure out the answer to now.
It's one of the,
it's one of the ironies of,
of literary history that this poem,
which is really all about
riddles and secrets,
this poem surely poses the
biggest riddle for that scholarly,
the academic study of,
of Milton.
It has proven nearly impossible
for scholars of Milton
to determine when it was
the Samsung agonists ds to determine or
authoritatively are definitively when it
was that this text was written.
Um,
and so in that respect,
it's utterly different from the,
the other works of Milton's that can be
dated with much more authoritative flame.
Samsung agonist is, we do know
this, it first appears in 1671,
it's published alongside
paradise regained.
So you have the title page
of that 1671 volume paradise,
regained a poem and for books.
And then in a little
little type phase two,
which is added Samson
agonist cheese and a,
and actually the Hughes
Edition [inaudible] produces
for you just this title
page. It's on page four 70. Um,
but there's no hard evidence for the
date of the composition of the poem.
And there are conflicting accounts
as of course you can imagine of the,
of the date of composition.
So I want to spend a little bit of time
here and I'll just do this briefly. Um,
thinking about the various
scholarly accounts of the, of,
of when it was that Milton
wrote Samsung agonists, ds.
Because all of these theories I think
concerning the placement of Samson
agonists,
ds in the miltonic Canon assume in
one way or another that this poem is
autobiographical or that there's some
kind of intimate autobiographical
component, uh, to, to,
to this remarkable work
as if the assumption is,
is that on some level Sampson agonists,
ds almost necessitates a type
of biographical reading. So,
uh, first and this is the most popular
theory of the dating of the poem. Um,
and it's the one I happened to, uh,
and that most people subscribe to. Um,
it's the theory that places Samson
agonists ds as Milton's last poem,
which means that this is a poem that's
written well after, uh, we will,
after the middle of the 1660s,
Milton seems to have started writing
paradise regained around 1665.
So it would have been after that
at some point well into the Stewart
restoration.
And this reading really suggested Samson
to the extent that this is a dramatic
reading of the poem,
suggest that Samson is like Milton,
the great political hero or the
erstwhile great political hero.
Samson had almost led the Hebrews to
freedom by destroying so many of the
Philistines with his extraordinary
divinely inspired violence.
But the Hebrew leaders failed to join
Samsung in this mission and they ruin
their chance for freedom
from the Felicity and yoke.
And in the 60s,
50s and in the 1660s,
Milton was always continually representing
himself and just this same light with
the help of Milton's own, uh,
aggressively propagandistic efforts.
The English had begun a tick to,
to fulfill the promise of a,
of something like a full fledged
revolution. But the parlor,
the weak minded parliamentary leaders had
failed to carry it out and out of some
sort of a moral,
moral weakness,
the English people began to yearn
again for a subjection to, to,
to the Stuart monarchy and its response.
It's in response to the tone of political
disappointment that we can read in
Samsung agonists,
Ds,
that scholars are led to date this
work as the late one as a final poem,
the final poem.
Now the second theory of the date of
the composition of Samsung agonists.
These places it in the late 1640s in the
period somewhere between 1647 and 1653
and this reading suggests
that Samson agonists,
ds constitutes Milton's first great
response to the onset of his blindness by
placing the poem in this period,
you and you can tell what's gone well,
what scholars are responding to
in the poem with this theory,
they're clearly trying to make some
sense of the tremendous amount of pathos.
And, and you could actually say the
tremendous amount of self pity, uh,
that charges a Milton's treatment
of Samson's Samson's blindness.
Now the third theory of the,
of the poems composition places it even
earlier in Milton's career during the,
during the early 1640s, this is the
period in which Milton was revived.
Ra was writing the divorce pamphlets.
And in this account, the poem is,
is the center of the poem becomes the,
the betrayal that are become the center
of the poem becomes a reflection or some
sort of representation of the betrayal.
Milton must've experienced
himself when his wife,
his wife of six weeks, Mary
Powell left him, um, uh, just,
just, just abandoned him. It seemed,
uh, she, she went home to her parents.
Now in the poem in Samson Agonists,
[inaudible] Dolly law,
you'll remember she was a Philistine.
She was a member of a political
tribe that had so oppressed.
The Hebrews and Mary Pals family had,
had all been royalist during the English
civil wars and to so, so to some extent,
Mary Powell, perhaps Mary Powell
herself. Um, what, what was,
it was a royalist.
And so the,
the leanings at least of the Powell
family, um, it has been conjectured, um,
contributed significantly to what turned
out to be merely the temporary erosion
of Milton's first marriage.
And according to this theory,
then the main thrust of Sampson agonists,
ds isn't exclusively political. Um,
but it's domestic or
domestic and political.
And Milton uses a biblical story
to reinvent. And in some way to,
to work through, uh, you know,
the private disaster that was,
that was the early portion of
his marriage to Mary Powell.
Now I think the third theory is
it, it has to be wrong, um, that,
that Samsung agonists, Ds was written so
early in Milton's career in the 1640s,
but,
uh,
I'm personally much too invested in the
notion that this is the last poem, um,
to, to, to have its status
be relinquished as a,
as a post restoration work. But
nonetheless, I want to think about that,
that third option that I've,
that I've just mentioned and to focus
on the nature of the relation of the
nature of Milton's representation
of the relation of Samson to Dilla.
Two Dalai Lama in this poem,
um,
which is an undeniable and undeniably
powerful aspect of this work.
Let me, um, let me, uh,
just digress here for a moment and
explain to you why I pronounced her name
Dolly Law and not Delilah. So when
I'm, when I used the word Delilah,
this lecture that will be referring to
the character in the Old Testament from
the book of judges,
the name with an h on the end,
a Milton doesn't have an h on the
end. He uses the Latin spelling, um,
from the Latin Bible of all
the characters in Samson.
Agonisti so the father is
Manawa rather than Minoa. Um,
he makes up the name [inaudible] but
it's along the same sort of Latin Nate
lines of DOL, Layla and Manoa. Um,
who knows why Milton wants to class
size these names rather than using,
uh, the English transliteration
of the, of the Hebrew. Um,
it's been conjectured that is just, it
sounds prettier. Uh, you have a line like
the sumptuous Dolly
love floating this way,
those extraordinary doctorals that
seem incredibly central and seductive.
You couldn't have that with Delilah.
There's some shoe was Delilah floating
this way? It just doesn't, it's not as,
it's not a sexy. Okay. That
was just a, a pronunciation.
Degression.
Now the evidence for Milton's,
uh,
for the scholars who, who
date this poem as, as, as,
as a really early one, is usually
taken from the scene in Milton's life.
Um, that actually was narrated for us
by Milton's nephew, Edward Philips.
So I'm going to ask you
to turn to Milton's nephew
Edward Phillips's biography
of Milton at the end of the hues edition.
So this is page 1032 in the Hughes.
This is Phillips, his account of
how Milton and Mary Powell reunited.
And it's an a, it's a, it's a,
it's an absolutely adorable narrative
and involves an elaborate trick straight
staged by friends of both
Milton and of Powell.
So we learned here and we
learn that it's a, it's a,
it's an amazing little window into what
the texture of this man's life was like.
A Milton was evidently in the habit
in the six weeks he lived alone as the
abandoned husband.
He was in the habit of visiting a friend.
We don't know who this guy was,
but a friend named Blackborow
and according to Phillips,
this is the top of the right hand
column according to Phillips.
It was at black Burrow's house that the
scheme to reunite the couple to reunite
them was pulled off.
So I'm quoting here from
Phillips one time above the rest,
he,
John Melton making his usual visit.
The wife was ready in another room and
on a sudden he was surprised to see one
whom he thought to have never seen more
making submission and begging pardon on
her knees before him.
He might probably at first make some
so show of aversion and rejection,
but partly his own generous nature.
And this is the loving Phillips
who so admires the uncle, um,
but partly his own generous nature.
More inclined to reconciliation then to
perseverance in anger and revenge and
partly the strong intercession.
Have friends on both sides.
Soon brought him to an act of oblivion
and affirm league of peace for the
future. And Mary Powell and John Milton
get back together again and they,
they have a, they have a child,
they have a few children.
Um,
this,
this seen bears and obvious resemblance
to the initial entrance of Dolly law
into the poem. Samson agonists, ds. Um,
now there's, there's no proof. Of
course. Then Milton Samson is a,
is a reworking of this biographical
event in the stormy life. That was,
that was Milton's domestic,
the Stormy's career of Hilton's domestic,
uh,
domestic life. Um, there's no proof
that this event ever happened at all.
And my guest actually is that Phillips
who's writing this biographical
narrative, well after the
publication of Samsung agonists,
Ds is actually staging his account of
this moment in Milton's life in some ways,
a reworking of the analogous moment
from Samson agonist. These, um,
I think he's giving us an, an imaginative
engagement of Sampson agonists decent.
He's probably because he's,
he wants to stave off what
he knows will be the easy,
obvious auto biographical reading that
we'll bring to Milton's poetic death,
a representation of a perfectly
disastrous marriage. So I don't,
I don't actually trust
Phillips's biography here,
but I want to linger on this passage for
just another moment because I think it
starts to aluminate.
Uh,
one of the most puzzling aspects
of Sampson agonists, ds. Um,
look at that.
Look at Phillips is metaphor in the
last sentence that I just quoted.
Milton's own generous nature brought him
to an act of oblivion and affirm league
of peace for the future.
Phillips is alluding here
to actual political events,
political events that took
place not in the 1640s.
When this reunion,
we know this reunion occurred,
but after the restoration that the act
of oblivion and the League of peace are
both actual political events that
followed the restoration of the Stuart
monarchy in 1660.
So the royalists in 1660
passed the act of oblivion,
the act of oblivion,
that profit prohibited
any further punishment of
puritans who were seen to have
behaved suspiciously, uh,
during the revolution. So in a,
in a gesture of magnanimity,
the royalists were agreeing to
be oblivious. They would forget,
they would forget the crimes of
the Puritan parliamentarians.
And one of the most notable beneficiaries
in fact of this act of oblivion was
Milton himself, Milton,
whose life was I think,
really mercifully spared. Um,
uh, after the registration,
he could easily have been prosecuted
and executed for his composition of the
regicide. Trina says, then once, I
think it's fascinating what Phillips is,
is doing here.
He situation,
he situates the relation of husband
and wife in the context of a political
accord, a political agreement between
two warring parties. And, and,
and in doing so, he's reproducing, I
think, one of the strangest aspects.
And it is a really strange
aspect of this poem that's the,
the remarkable conjunction
of the representation of
love and the representation
of, of war, uh, the,
the militaristic nature of sexual
relations in Samsung agonists, Ds,
and also the disturbingly sexual
nature of political conflict as it's
represented in Samson agonist ds and to,
and we won't,
we'll pursue that in a moment.
So one of the curious elements of,
of Phillips as account of Mary Powell,
his return is the implicit reversal,
I think, of, of political identities here.
Milton becomes the royalist passing the
act of oblivion by way of forgiving Mary
Powell and that, so the, these domestic
enemies Powell and Milton have become,
it says, if they become mirror
images of one another, the, the,
the moral alignment of their
identities suddenly becomes in this,
in this retelling of it. Um, vague
and, and indistinct. And it'll,
in a lot of ways,
they're kind of pictured like Satan and
the son of God and paradise regained.
Satan's in so many ways, seems to be the
son of God's evil twin. There are mirror,
they're mirror images of one another,
but obviously they represent, uh,
utterly different things.
The Sun you'll remember in paradise
regained only discovers his identity in
paradise in that poem in
opposition to Satan. And the,
this is something that the late poems
of Milton are continually doing.
They're exploring what we can think
of as the dialectical nature of,
of identification.
Um,
virtue cannot exist in a vacuum.
And in fact,
I think for Milton, the, the
knowledge of oneself can't, uh,
come about in, in, in a vacuum. Um,
any virtuous identity will inevitably be
the process will be the product of some
kind of antithetical process of some sort
of agonistic encounter with ones with
ones opposite.
Now the antithetical construction of
the heroes identity is really central to
this poem, a Samsung agonists, ds. And,
and I think keeping this in mind
will help us try to make sense of,
of some of its most troubling components.
And I think the components
of Sampson agonist,
these are as troubling as anything
you'll find anywhere in, uh,
in the reading for this course.
Um,
and for me what's most
troubling is this fat.
And this is an undeniable
unquestionable fact. Samson agonists,
[inaudible] is the or gives
us the intensivist expression
of misogyny that you
will find in the miltonic Canon. And
that's because this program goes further,
I think, than any of Milton's other poems
in narrowing the problem of identity.
And this is a problem that Milton
has been concerned with all along,
but narrowing this larger problem of
identity to the much more circumscribed,
the much more focused question, a
problem of sexual identity, the,
the masculine heroes identity can only
be established by contraries by an some
sort of antithetical process.
Samsung can only identify
himself as a hero by rejecting,
by actively excluding absolutely
everything that's not masculine.
Every rejecting everything
that's not heroic,
rejecting everything that's not Samson
and it's a,
and it becomes a kind of violent
process of rejection. Um,
the character Samson is
continually impelled,
it seems by a powerful
need to expel all forms of,
of sensual pleasure,
the types of pleasure that we know
to be prized and sanctioned by, by,
by, by Milton, um,
forms of sexual pleasure that Milton
will identify and Samson agonists,
ds as types of femininity.
And all of this has to be
expelled by Samson from Samson.
And as you reread the poem,
I think you'll, you'll,
you'll be shocked if you
haven't been shocked already.
You will be shocked by the violence of
the really weirdly sexualized rhetoric
that makes up so much of the,
the metaphorical texture of this poem.
I'll give you just one example.
There are innumerable examples.
You may have noticed how this poem refers
routinely to the Philistine enemies as
the, um, as the uncircumcised. And,
and this is to be on some level,
this is to be expected.
The Bible refers to havens
as the uncircumcised.
And so this is conventional, we could
say. But Milton, of course, it goes,
goes needlessly,
goes further than that.
And he actually refers to
the enemies of the Hebrews.
As for skins,
with his sort of bones,
Samson slew a thousand for skins.
This is an unbelievable
synecdoche [inaudible].
He being the rhetorical trope
of using a part for a whole.
And Milton as far as I can tell,
had absolutely no precedent whatsoever
for the use of this predict earlier
particular synectics [inaudible] to refer
to an entire people the enemies of the
uncircumcised enemies of the Hebrews.
There's a kind of sexual violence
continually welling up in the,
in the rhetoric used to
describe political violence.
Um,
and think about what that,
what that implies to slay a thousand
for skins is in some way to imagine a
military victory as something like a mass
circumcision or symbolically some type
of mass mass castration.
And this is just one,
one of many examples of,
of,
of a related kind of figurative
pattern in Samsung agonists, ds, um,
political violence seems so
continually to be figured in the,
in the literary rhetoric of
this poem as a sexual cleansing,
as a kind of purging the painful
excision of something unclean,
um, something presumably unnecessary
and something excessively sensual.
Look, for example, at the way this,
this text sexualizes the key event,
um, in Samson's life, which is
of course the loss of his hair.
Uh, look at Samson's account
of the moment of his, the,
the moment at which he lost his strength.
This is a page five 64 in the Hughes
lies lines five 29 and following
now when the book of judges,
a Samson tells Delilah that the secret
of his strength lies in his hair.
Only after her continued verbal assaults,
she pleads with him,
she nags him, she pleads with him,
unremittingly to tell her his,
his secret. And finally he just freelance.
That's the, that's the scriptural story.
But in Sampson's accounting, in Melton
story, Dalai Lama doesn't harass,
harass Samson into telling the secret.
She seduces him.
Look at line five 29.
This is Samsung talking and here he's the,
he describes, he describes himself
as the cock of the walk here.
Fearless of danger,
like a petty God.
I walked about admired of all
and dreaded on hostile ground.
None Daring Maya Front,
then swollen with pride into the snare.
I fell of bear,
fallacious looks venereal.
Trains softened with
pleasure and voluptuous life.
Now the voluptuous life that he's
describing here in line five 30 forest.
What is this?
Uh,
I think this is what we would
have to name the life of marriage.
Um, the, the,
the woman he's to calling a deceitful
concubine is actually in Milton's telling
of this story. Samson's
wife. And there's a,
there's a profound confusion about the
cause of his weakness here. Was it,
was it the actual act of
his head being shaved or,
or simply the state, the
condition of marriage, this
condition of marriage itself.
Um, listen to Milton's
figuration of the event,
of the cutting of his hair.
And,
and you tell me if this is an unusually
charged even for Milton with I'm a
pretty intense degree of sexual anxiety
at length to lay my head and hallowed
pledge of all my strength
in the lascivious lap of
a deceitful concubine who
shore me like a tame weather.
All my precious fleece.
Um, you, you haven't, you haven't,
you have an image here of,
of sexual intercourse.
This is the,
this has been suggested in a brilliant
reading of this poem by John Gallery, um,
embedded in the image of Samson's head
in the doll and Dolly Liz lascivious lap.
Um, her, her violation of Samson, her
cutting of his hair seems almost extreme,
inextricable here from a,
from a perfectly simple seemingly,
it's never simple of course, but
an act of conjugal intercourse. Um,
but the figurative
chain doesn't end there.
It gets better or worse depending
on your, on your perspective. Um,
because in this play,
marital intercourse is equated,
at least figuratively,
is equated with castration,
the cutting off of the hallowed
pledge of Samson's strength.
And Samson makes this explicit when he
describes himself as a team, whether,
but what is a, whether you ask a
whether is a, is a castrated ram,
the slot,
the slayer of a thousand for
skins is himself slain and,
and part of the intensely
violent figurative world of,
of Samson agonist. These,
this is a world that continually
identifies Dolly Luz.
Betrayal as a kind of
castration and castration
itself has nothing more than the
male experience in marriage.
Um,
a darker or more anxious reading of the
relation between the sexes. You will,
you'll have a,
you'll have a difficult time finding.
Uh,
let's look now at Dolly Liz own language.
turn to page 570 in the Hughes.
Um,
a round line hundred 803,
eight [inaudible] three.
Uh,
and I think Darlene was languages and a
lot of ways just as powerful though it's
configured a little differently,
much more than Samson.
Dolly La contradicts herself
throughout this poem. And, and the,
and the contradictions have proven
baffling, uh, to, to the poems critics.
Now, one way of reading the
character dollar law is to,
is to insist that are
contradictions a point point out,
emphasize her mendacity. These are
just simply lies that she's telling.
And in a lot of ways Milton does seem
to be setting her up as a type of, of,
of Satan.
Satan who own mount knife eighties at
the beginning of book four of paradise
lost was continually contradicting
himself. Um, and, and,
and critics have typically dismiss Dolly
Liz explanations for justifications of
her behavior,
um,
and with the assumption that Milton is
simply trying to discredit her and it's
not a, it's not an unjustifiable
assumption. And, and,
and I think that's because the,
the central contradiction of for
discourse involves her use of two types of
arguments. The first is an
erotic or romantic argument.
And the second argument she deploys
is a political one. And once again,
it's this conjunction,
the conjunction of the sexual and the
political that in this poem proves so,
so unsettling and so,
so puzzling. So let's,
let's look at Dolly Luz reasons
for betraying her husband.
This is her first argument line eight
oh three. She's essentially saying,
I wanted you at home. You were always
going out. You're working all the time.
I knew that liberty would draw the
fourth to perilous enterprises while I at
home set full of cares and fears whaling
thy absence in my widowed bed here.
I should still enjoy the
day and night here at home.
I should still enjoy the day and night.
Mine and loves prisoner.
I unmanned you.
She's saying because I loved you so much.
That's the gist of the argument.
Um,
Dalai Lama's second argument is entirely
different. Um, and it's the, it's, it's,
it's distinct from the complaint
of the housewife that we just,
that we just looked at.
Look at the top. No,
look at the very bottom of page five 71.
This is line eight 57 and following here,
Dali law tells us that she, she had to
betray Samson for political reasons.
She had to do it to liberate her people.
The Philistines,
the priest was not behind.
Darla law says,
but ever at my ear preaching how
meritorious with the Gods it would be to
ensnare an irreligious
dishonor of day gone.
What had I to oppose against
such powerful arguments.
Only my love of the how long
debate and combated in silence.
All these reasons with
hard contest at length,
that grounded maxim so rife and celebrated
in the mouths of wisest men that to
the public good private respects,
must yield with grave authority,
took full possession of me and prevailed.
Virtue as I thought,
truth duty.
So in joining and Delillo here gives
us an extraordinary revelation.
She turns out to be on some level.
She turns out to be the mirror
image of the great heroic Samson.
She plays the same role as
the deliverer of her people.
She's the deliverer of the Philistines
that Samson plays for the Hebrews.
She defends the Gentile God day gone and,
and Samson,
her husband defends, uh, the Hebrew God,
Yahweh or Jehovah. Um, they're,
it's in direct competition here.
They're, they're political opposites.
And Milton is playing with the kind of
something approaching a sort of cultural
relativism by means of his
representation of this competition.
There is however, a difference
between them and it's a difference.
We have no choice but
to, to, to deal with the,
the difference between
them is that Dolly law,
the wife sacrifices private concerns
for a public commitment to her people.
She yields in her word, she reels
private respects to the public good.
This is precisely what
Samson was supposed to do.
But of course this is exactly
what Samson failed to do.
So the a and a lot of ways the,
these two explanations,
these two arguments of dollar
loans contradict one another.
And on the literal level of the plot,
the first motive,
the motive appropriate for
a wife is revealed as a lie.
But the, but the presence of
these two conflicting motives, um,
bespeaks more,
I think,
than the mere fact that Dalai Lama is a
liar or some way in some way the Dolly
loves a satanic figure WHO's Justin?
A very embodiment of evil.
That these two conflicting
arguments really speak to
Samson's deepest anxieties.
And perhaps the deepest anxieties of
this poem, Sampson Agonists, these,
the prospect of domestic pleasure is
invariably a dangerous one for Samson.
And that's because domestic success,
success at home for Samson
is indistinguishable from,
from political defeat. Um, Darlene lists
two arguments are, are, are, are utterly.
It's as if inside of Satan,
Satan Samson's head,
they're utterly intermingled with one
another and inextricable in Samson psyche
in the severely restricted,
circumscribed world of this
hero's consciousness. Um,
domestic comfort and political failure.
S turn out to be something like one in
the same thing. I'm in both instances,
the hero is seen to have
relinquished his masculinity.
He's undergone a humiliating defeat.
And with this dual identification of
Dhalla as wife and us and as fierce
warrior,
um,
you have a sense of the fragility of
a powerful sense of the fragility of
masculine, heroic consciousness
as it's represented in this,
in this text.
Okay,
turn now to Dhalla's
final offer to Samson.
This is line nine 20 a the
middle of the huge page five 73.
The most tempting and the most terrifying
offer of Dolly laws is her offer to
nurse Samsung.
He's old.
He's blind, um, to nurse him
after his release from the prison.
So Dolly tells Samson I to the Lord's
will intercede not doubting their
favorable ear,
that I may fetch the from forth this
load some prison house to abide with me
where my redoubled love and care
with nursing diligence to my glad,
to me,
glad office may ever tend about the
two old age with her nursing diligence.
Dolly luck can perform the work
of, she can be Samson's nurse, uh,
better yet she can function
as Samson's mother.
I think that's essentially the gist of
her argument. Sampson has already claimed,
we know this was at line six 33.
He's claimed that he is a nurse Ling of
God and he's been struggling throughout
this text to establish himself as a child,
not of human parents,
um, certainly not of this
perfectly sweet natured, but v uh,
kind of adult dad of his [inaudible].
Um,
but he's a child solely exclusively
of God himself. And so it's,
Dolly was offered to nurse Samson
that elicits his most violent,
the most powerful fit of rage.
And it's, it's, it's horrible.
Look at line nine 52,
Darla says,
let me approach at least,
and touch by hand
in Samson's response.
Shocking,
not for thy life.
Less fierce remembrance.
Wake my sudden rage to
tear the joint by joint.
It's Dolly Liz.
Simple offer to touch Samson's hand,
uh,
has received an extraordinarily
extreme, uh, reaction.
And it's usually thought this,
this typically how we read this.
I think that the fierce remembrance
that will awaken Samson is his room,
is his memory of his powerful
desire for her. A memory that,
that he has to forestall with
this violent rejection. But,
but I think the violence of
this, of this reaction, uh,
surely exceeds the violence. Myriad
merely have a remembered sexual passion.
This is,
this is too intense even for that.
And I think it's possible to see in this
reaction to Dolly has offered to nurse
Samson another memory that,
that that has been suppressed.
Um, and, and it's not just a memo,
not just the remembrance of a
sexual, bisexual love. And our,
our best clue to this suppressed memory
might come from that aspect of this
story of Samson from the book of judges
that has been most notice simply have
suppressed, perhaps it's been
circumcised from Milton's,
from Milton's own poem.
Um,
you'll remember from your reading of
the poem that Milton is continually
referring to the Heavenly Messenger
who descended to prophesied Samson's
Sampson's greatness. Uh, this
was happening well before
Samson was actually born,
but to whom?
To whom did this heavenly messenger speak,
the angel spoke according
to the judge's story,
the angel spoke to Samson's mother or a
character who figures prominently in the
scriptural original of the story,
but who was very carefully excluded
from the text of Samson agonists. These,
um, and I'm, I'm, I'm indebted
for this point to, uh, to, uh,
a wonderful reading of this poem by, uh,
I think she's a great Milton Krennic.
Her name is Stevie
Davies. Um, in, in this,
in Samson's violent rejection of Dalai
Lama and his rejection of her offer to
nurse him in his old age,
Samson is rejecting on some
level the very existence of a,
of his mother.
He's denying the obvious fact that
he had ever been mothered at all. Um,
W which is another way of course of
don denying his humanity of denying his
status as a creature has creativeness.
Now it has been years now
Milton has four years,
addressed himself to the attraction and
also to the danger of the fantasy of
heroic self sufficiency. Um, I'll,
I'll just remind you of book
five of Paradise Lost in
which Milton explored the,
the fantasy of self creation.
Satan's remarkable.
And of course, implausible claim that
he was, that, that he was self be got.
Satan needed to deny he wanted to
deny God's agency in his creation.
Now Samson's case is related,
but of course it's a little different.
I'm Samson wants more than
anything to be a nurse Ling of God.
And it's as if he needs to deny that he
had ever had any tie to the womb or to
the breast of an earthly mother if he
is to be the nursing exclusively of God.
Of course,
it's the fact the existence of the mother.
That is the thing that
guarantees the truth,
which is that he is inescapably human.
Um,
but like us,
Samson obviously owes a fundamental
physical debt of fundamental physiological
debt and obligation to a mother.
And,
and there's a sense in this poem that
the very existence of the mother of any
mother seems to doom all of our attempts
to think of ourselves as independent,
as, as autonomous in any
way self sufficient beings,
or to think of ourselves as beings whose
primary debt can be exclusively to the
heavenly father.
And Milton Milton had been so bold in,
in,
in paradise regained to emphasize
the thorough going humanity of the,
uh, of the son of God. He had, he had the,
the, the son of God and paradise regained,
had no more divine knowledge about
his situation. It seemed then,
then we could possibly have had,
um,
that it's in, that we're, we're,
Milton should have been anxious
about the humanity of the hero. Um,
but all of that theological anxiety
that should have existed in paradise
regained seems to have been displaced
onto, onto Sampson agonists, ds,
um, turn to the very opening
of Samson agonist. These,
the,
the exquisitely beautiful lines
with which Milton begins this poem.
A little onward.
Len did thy guiding hand to these
dark steps a little further on,
a little onward lend by guiding hand
to these dark steps a little further on
Milton Milton's poem opens with,
with these beautiful lines
addressed by Samson to someone
presumably who's holding his hand,
who is touching his hand.
And he's an assisting his
movements in his blindness,
Samson's wandering steps and slow.
And,
and the sense of absolute dependence
here is, is, is that with which we began,
this palm is overwhelming and it's often
argued that Milton is suggesting here
something like Samson's
complete dependence on God.
This is the nurse Ling of God.
After all,
Samson's ultimate victory comes from his
absolute submission to the will of God.
This much we will learn at the end
of the poem, but the character,
it's a character. In fact, it's
not. It's not, uh, the divinity.
The character leading Sampson around at
the opening of the play has never named
this characters never identified.
And this mysterious omission is,
is certainly has to be purposeful.
Um,
the, and the, and this is a,
another clever argument forwarded by
Stevie Davies that the unnamed character
holding Samson's hand reminds us here of
another unnamed character in the Samson
Story.
And that's of course Samson's mother
Samson as the champion of the Hebrews is
supposed to be able to submit himself
utterly to the will of the father.
Not Manoa but the heavenly father.
But the play reminds us overwhelmingly
and continually that even the greatest
heroes are our subject.
And this,
you can tell that Milton was an enormous
fan of Shakespeare stragedy Cory
Elena's which to explore a
lot of the same problems, um,
that even the greatest heroes are subject
to other far less dignified forms of,
of submission.
And that human figure most likely to
lend a hand to one steady steps is
obviously the mother that the, the, the,
the person in the child's life who
touches the child's hand and serves as his
first guide, first teacher in,
in paradise,
regained Milton was after all that
we went through in paradise regained,
Milton was able to allow the sun to
return home to his mother's house.
He unobserved home to his mother's house,
private returned,
the son of God had successfully proven
his son ship to the heavenly father and
he could thereby a Ford to
return to the domestic space. Uh,
of course it's a domestic space that
had been utterly purged of any, any,
any type of sensuality.
But in Samson agonists does this,
this space,
the place of maternal affection and
domestic piece of just happiness in one's
domestic life is continually
threatening to contaminate the hero.
Um, and obviously this is a hero who has
a lot less well adjusted. We could say,
um, then the son of God, um,
I that didn't make any sense, but on
some level, at least to me it does. Um,
heroism in this poem depends on
the heroes ability to exclude,
uh, to expunge from his system
any attachment to the home.
Any dependency on an
origin that could come,
could compete with the ultimate origin,
which is of course that if
they haven't only father,
and that's why this poem
is continually voicing.
It's terrible conviction in the
necessary exclusion of all things,
of all things feminine. And
it's in respect, I think,
to this exclusion that we
can best understand the,
the horrible violence and the terrible
misogyny charging the language of,
of, of Samson agonists,
these, this, this poem,
this play that's not really a play.
Um,
seems to be arguing for
the necessary exclusion
of the feminine from the Hero's life.
And if that's true,
if that is the old one of the ultimate
arguments that Samson agonists,
ds is actually making than where
I think we also have in this poem,
the pain and also the painful rhetoric.
Um,
we have the,
the painful sense that Milton gives us
of the cost of that exclusion here in,
in,
in Milton's final poem,
we have an acknowledgement that the
process whereby one becomes the miltonic
hero is potentially ruinous.
Okay. That's a, that's it for today.